you're watching the free pilot training
channel where today we're going to dive
into a lesson on class bravo airspace
we're going to talk about what you need
to know as far as characteristics
rules vfr weather minimums and equipment
required to operate in this airspace
let me preface this lesson by saying
class bravo is not the best place to
learn how to fly
but you are required to know the rules
since as a private pilot you can legally
fly here
now that that's done let's take a look
at some of the characteristics of bravo
airspace the first thing that you'll
notice is that this airspace is
surrounded by big blue markings on the
vfr sectional
now as i mentioned in the last lesson
you can remember class b airspace by
thinking b
is for busy but you could also remember
b is for blue to mark that airspace
let's take a closer look at the bravo
airspace surrounding memphis
you'll notice that it's divided up into
segments and if you take a look at it
from the side
it would resemble an upside down wedding
cake if you look inside each section
you'll notice that each is marked by
some numbers that look like they're
improper fractions
these aren't fractions though this is
the altitude for the top
and the bottom of that bravo airspace in
this section
expressed in hundreds so the bravo
airspace in this section this girl is
pointing to
starts at 5000 msl and goes up to 1 0
000 msl this section starts at 3 000 msl
and goes up to 1
0 000. now you'll notice that this
middle section goes all the way down to
the surface
but you can see how i could actually fly
beneath this air space as long as i stay
below this lower altitude
okay time for a pop quiz let's say i'm
in this northern section
at 2500 feet msl am i in the class bravo
airspace
the answer is no i'm 500 feet beneath
the shelf since this section starts at
3000 feet
okay now let's take a look at some of
the rules in class b airspace
first of all you have to have your
private pilot certificate
however a student pilot may fly solo in
bravo with the proper endorsements and
as long as they follow all the other
rules
the biggest rule is that you must be
cleared by atc to go in there
you don't have to be cleared to go under
the shelf but you definitely have to be
cleared before you can go into the bravo
airspace
let's take just a second to look at some
proper radio communications going into
this airspace
if you haven't made too many radio calls
a good format is who they are
who you are where you are and what you
want
today i'm flying skyhawk 12345 at 6500
msl
and i'm 40 nautical miles to the
northwest i want to fly into west
memphis which is a small airport under
the class b
shelf now legally you don't have to talk
to anybody as long as you stay out of
the class b airspace by staying below
these altitudes
so we either need to start descending to
get below that airspace
or we need to contact memphis approach
let's give them a quick call
memphis approach skyhawk 12345
40 miles to the northwest 6500
inbound for west memphis with the
numbers now they're trying to find you
on radar
first they're going to assign you a
squawk code then if you forgot any part
of that previous radio call
or they didn't hear it they're going to
ask you for that information
and they'll start giving you
instructions and other important
information
let's assume i have a beautiful radio
voice and they heard every word
skyhawk12345 memphis approach
descend and maintain 5000 squawk 0123
altimeter 2909 or 2. i'll answer this
radio call in just a second so you can
hear the correct response
but first can i fly into the class bravo
airspace now
no you can't you must hear the phrase
cleared into the class bravo airspace
now let's respond to memphis approach we
have to say our call
sign then make sure you read back all
the information they just gave you
they want to make sure you heard all the
numbers correctly
decent and maintain 5000 squawk 0123
altimeter 299 or 2 skyhawk12345
then once they find you on radar you
might hear something like this
skyhawk12345 memphis approach
radar contact cleared into class bravo
report the field in site
now we can go into class b airspace
to finish up this radio call i'll just
repeat exactly what they said
cleared into class bravo we will report
the field skyhawk12345
before we continue comment below if you
found that valuable and you'd like to
see more training on radio
communications
also don't forget to subscribe and hit
the bell if you haven't already so you
can be alerted
every time there's a new lesson next
let's look at the weather minimums for
the class bravo airspace
that means this is the worst the weather
can be and you can still fly vfr
for class b airspace this is three
statute miles visibility and clear the
clouds
visibility simply means how far you can
see
and this can be impaired by smoke haze
fog rain
all kinds of different stuff so we need
to be able to see
at least three miles to fly legally in
class b airspace
there of cloud simply means that you can
fly right up to a cloud
as long as you don't touch it that's
because there could be planes on an ifr
clearance flying through those clouds
and that wouldn't be very much fun
running into one of those guys
next let's take a look at the equipment
required before we can go into bravo
airspace
first is a working two-way radio and
that makes sense because we have to be
cleared in order to go into that
airspace
we also need to have a working
transponder with altitude reporting
in fact it doesn't matter what altitude
you're flying at
if you fly inside of this magenta ring
which is called the mode c veil
you must have a transponder with
altitude reporting
the moti veil is a 30 nautical mile ring
around an airfield with class b air
space
our last equipment requirement is adsb
this stands for automatic dependent
surveillance broadcast and it's kind of
a newer requirement
from the faa this equipment's designed
to help air traffic control find your
airplane
easier anytime you're in the mote c veil
you have to have working adsb
and it doesn't matter which altitude
you're at for this one either
and you still need it if you fly over
ten thousand feet
i hope you learned something today don't
forget to smash like for me and share
this video with a friend
and i'll see you in the next lesson
aircraft calling safe position